and here it is the year-end event got a
dress up look sharp you know how it is
these are the top 10 best movies of 2010
for my opinion just remember and do keep
in mind that I didn't actually see every
movie that came out I haven't seen
buried and people rave about buried
buried might be one of the top 10 best
but I didn't see it so I can't say it is
and without further ado here we go
number 10 you said number 10 kicks ass
and yes yes it does kick all that ass
now kick ass is the first of a couple
movies that in my opinion will get
absolutely robbed in the box office in
2010 kick ass is an awesome and
ludicrously outrageous superhero movie
that really pushes the bounds of what a
movie can and cannot do a little girl
gets spin kick in the face I'm not down
for beating kids or anything like that
but even if you hate kick ass you got to
give it credit for the balls number 9
True Grit is truly gritty doesn't really
work like kick ass kicks ass and this is
probably a little higher on a lot of
other people's top 10 list but this
movie surprised me I really did like it
I expected a really artsy ass Western
about revenge what I got was a little
girl who stole the show a badass old
dude and a really realistic manhunt and
every time I see a review bitching about
the needless violence just makes me like
the movie even more dude totally gets
shot in the face it's awesome number
eight the legend of the guardians the
owls of ga'hoole did I say that any
gayer this one also surprised me I was
hoping it would be good I did not expect
it to be on my top 10 list but the
director of 300 made a movie about owls
badass mean how often can you say that
probably never before because the
director of 300 has never made an alum
moving until now so you know one yeah
one time yeah the movie felt a little
rushed in a couple of parts and it
should have been longer than hour and a
half minimum two hours but a rated PG
movie about owls should not have made me
feel like I did when I watched Lord of
the Rings for the first time but
watching this movie the feeling was
quite similar for that number eight
number seven the triumphant return of
the old-school ish feeling of Disney
with tangled remember when Disney was
just the pinnacle of really good
animated movies well in 2010 they came
back to show us they still got it they
mix the old-school classic feel of the
old Disney
with new modern and relevant characters
characters that most people can relate
to or at least like true it's not a
classic like The Lion King but it might
be because it's just two months old
number six that's right most people use
it admit it and this is where my comment
section blows up with people who don't
use Facebook the social network it's
funny when this movie came out people
were like a movie about Facebook lame
yes a movie about a digital
multibillion-dollar social networking
site in a predominantly digital age it's
worth knowing about and it's really well
done well acted well directed well
written and it's interesting I mean can
you really ask for more can you really
think of it this way you don't have to
have been in the loony bin - appreciate
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest so even
if you don't use Facebook it's worth
watching
number five and we're halfway done with
number five this second movie that was
robbed in the box office Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world you think you're badass
try taking on the world or at least
seven evil exes [ __ ] is not fun take it
from me this is honestly one of the most
unique movies of the year if you're an
old-school gamer of like the Legend of
Zelda variety or you've ever had a
girlfriend a girlfriend with maybe a
weirdo extra label and it's for you so
check it out but emphasis on the whole
gamer thing if you're a gamer sure movie
number four number four is the movie I
held off my top-10 list for a hundred
and twenty seven hours and I'm
absolutely glad I held off the list for
this this is the story of a guy who is
in the most grim of situations and he
really has to ask himself how bad do I
want to live it's well acted well
directed it affects you you think about
it long after the movies over and it
also makes you squirm definitely good
definitely an Oscar contender go check
it out if it's in the theater near you
number three Mark Wahlberg may be a [ __ ]
choice for Nathan Drake but he was a
great choice for Micky Ward in the
fighter and that's Micky Ward not make
you Roark I'm not saying that it's
different guy yeah Mark Wahlberg was
good but give Bale the Oscar seriously
this is just a good movie and a good
story about conflict family letting go
overcoming big-ass obstacles in the ring
as well as out and it pretty much tied
with my number two choice number two
that's right we're going for heart on
this one Toy Story 3 yes an animation
for my number two choice because it's
not meant for kids but for adults that
were once kids but also kids 100
twenty-seven hours may have been more
intense the fighter may have been more
real but Toy Story three man that just
hit me I don't know why from what I've
heard hit everybody I mean was the last
time you heard about people being that
United about one thing nonsense what
9/11 I'm serious it was good the movie
was good if you don't cry it's cuz you
held it back dad are you were raised by
Francis dollar hides mom number one
cuz you got a kind of sound like Patrick
Stewart when you say that you just do
number one and number one the best movie
of the year the movie for the heart the
mind and the soul you already know what
it is its inception this movie had it
all great action and awesome and unique
premise great actors saw the directing
solid script it's about the subconscious
like by default that's awesome and this
movie had the ending that as far as I
can tell is still the topic of many a
conversation so the king of the Year
inception so there it is folks that's my
top 10 what do you think what's your top
10 comment below let the world know what
did you like this year cuz you know the
show it's all about this it's all about
the interaction I give you [ __ ] I got a
heart Toy Story 3 was number 2 and in a
world of all balance stay tuned in the
next couple days for my top 10 worst
picks of the year
that's picks for worse top 10 worst
movies they're coming and of course if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more